bonjour je suis Emma Watson je suis tellement excitée d'
être ici en France
je joue dans le cercle aux côtés de
Tom Hanks ça sort le 12 juillet et
j'espère vraiment que vous l'apprécierez
et que nous pourrons le voir merci beaucoup
je  je suis un cercle il n'y a pas de problème que
nous ne pouvons pas résoudre nous pouvons guérir n'importe quelle maladie
et vous pouvez et faim les possibilités
sont infinies
nous avons Hamrick une place partout dans le
monde en ce moment les terroristes ne peuvent plus
cacher d'abord toutes ces données vont tout
est stocké ici je pourrais l'utiliser comment
tout savoir est bon mais savoir
tout s'améliore
vous